[تصفيق]
بالحماس والاعجاب استقبل عشرات الاطفال
ابطال مصارعه السته الذين شاركوا في
فعاليه بيستار لتعزيز التعلم العاطفي
ومكافحه التنمر حيث امتزجت القوه بالرسائل
التوعويه لرفض التنمر
الى هنا للتفاعل مع المجتمع فهناك فارق
بين البطوله داخل الحلبه وخارجها بين
الجماهير حيث نعامل بعضنا البعض باحترام
موسم الرياضه رحب بمشاهير المصارعين لنقل
قصصهم حول التنمر ومواجهتهم له عبر ترديد
كلمه كل نجما ولا تكن متمرا فالتفاعل مع
الاطفال زاد من الرغبه بالاستمرار في نقل
تلك الرساله في كل دول العالم
للتحدث مع الاطفال انا هنا يوضح لهم اهميه
الاحترام وان لا يكون متنمرين وكيفيه
التفاعل فيما بينهم بلطف هذه المنصه مفيده
جدا وانا عارف الشعور بالتنمر وهو سيء
فامنا مفيد نوضح لهم كيفيه الاستمتاع
بالحياه بايجابيه انه للشرف ان نتمكن من
فعل ذلك
وكذلك تعتقد بان هذا الامر مفيد جدا لان
الكثير من الاطفال يتابعون المصارعه
العالميه الحره وانا اعرف بان بعض
شخصياتنا تحومها بعض التساؤلات لذلك من
المهم جدا ان ناتي الى هنا وان نوضح لهم
بانهم في الحياه الحقيقيه من المهم جدا
نعامل الاخرين كما نحب ان يعاملونا اي
باحترام
قرر ابطال المصارعه استغلال قوتهم الجسديه
واعجاب الاطفال بهم للمره الثالثه خلال
مواسم الرياضه في التاكيد عليهم بان القوه
احيانا تكون في اللطف مع الاخرين
من الرياض شهد متروك العربيه